maybe he won't ever he just live in
server 2 forever I know so many this
some sad [__] because I used to work I
used to have a landscape business I knew
so many like elderly couples where they
had to like they had a paid off house
they had a reverse mortgage yet to make
[__] happen they're like yeah Miguel you
know these are like 80 86 [__]
9-year-old [__] grandmas and stuff
they're maybe the husband died they
didn't have the [__] it's it's
[__] really dude I not trying to tear
up but that's some sad [__] and they had
to like they they know they're getting
loone sharked and they had to [__]
RSE mortgage themselves just to survive
and well I guess I just got enough to
casket when I die and that's it and it's
like what the [__] you know that's
that's some sad sh I and and that's at
the local level just imagine at the
higher level you like like like HB HBC
or what was that big ass Bank HSBC HSBC
those [__] [__] those [__] by the
way they're [__] they're [__]
running money for the cartels and [__]
who who are getting paid by the Chinese
yeah who are running like yeah they're
running money for the cartels who are
getting money for the Chinese to [__]
flood the whole United States and Europe
with [__] fentanyl but besides that
one of the things that I got so pissed
off at during the 2000 housing crisis
because this came out they had to pay
fees for this is they were targeting
elderly black people and calling them
mud people because these he said these
dumb this is real by the way you can
look it up they said these dumb people
will sign anything we put in [__] in
front of them and they were and they
were so they were selling the worst type
of [__] loans to like elderly
African-American people just to [__]
gut them that's how evil these [__]
[__] are and [__] don't ever fall for
like this is why I'm so passionate about
crypto well that happened to my parents
during like the 2007 I mean not the the
variable but you got the variables what
the variable loans and stuff or what you
talking about I don't well I don't I
don't I don't know exactly what loan or
I don't know what they did I just know
they put their life savings they bought
a neighborhood and like my parents
weren't like they're not they're like
first generation like like my dad like
worked a lot growing up like my dad's
like the hardest worker they spent like
their whole life savings to buy a
neighborhood and like develop it and the
whole Market crashed now I don't know
they got their way out of it somehow I
don't know I just remember like they
they were going to lose like everything
like they were going to lose their house
they're going to like they like I think
his business was collateral I don't I
don't understand how loans work so
sorry but yeah but somehow they ended up
like figuring it out but yeah I remember
like that was like the scary like I
remember they were just so I was
literally little but I just remember
they were so stressed cuz it was like
they just they worked their whole lives
put everything into this and then boom
everything crashes this neighborhoods
well it wasn't a neighborhood it was
like a plot of land you know developing
L boogie yeah but yeah it's that was
that was a crazy time yeah and then and
then but that's also like this is also
why like I mean like first generation
immigrants or anything like that they
take risk and that's why they're in
these positions you have to like
sometimes you have to throw the dice but
it land it lands bad but this is like a
prefabricated of sort of event like they
like there's [__] if I have these
documents and stuff like there's these
groups if if you're high enough and
you're high enough in wealth inside of
um like some of these major Banks they
have these kind of like there's a report
that came out that America's not a
democracy the DU it's a plutocracy it's
it's completely controlled by the rich
completely it's just but but there's the
[__] up [__] is most countries are
plutocracies it really is it's all a
[__] it's all a [__] like it's all a
[__] smoking mirrors it's just in
America you like it's a little more free
or enough where you can you can still
this is why there's still the greatest
nation on Earth but I mean but you can
but these new indries that's why crypto
is like it's a vein where like it's wide
[__] open you can grab your lane and
you got it right this is a brand new
indust
like 2017 we were $640 billion at the
tippy top we crashed down to like
basically 100 or less than 100 um
billion dollars 20 in 2021 we hit 3.4
trillion we we're [__] at a trillion
right now we're going to 10 Gold's 10
trillion right now like and this is an
industry this is why so many people like
you see this how much money they they
steal is that it's a trillion dollar
industry it's it's a [__] it's
nothing like black Ross got 10 trillion
just liquid in cash and assets and stuff
you know and so this is what I'm telling
you like just getting like even a tenth
of that money and that being split among
so many people even just owning like 0.0
and a ton of zeros it's life Chang money
people are able to buy a house they're
able to have [__] families they're
able to not get divorce raped and stuff
because they're not getting
married but and then some women are able
and we've helped a lot of single women
and stuff you know or like some of them
are widows and stuff like and they've
been able to like their kids are fine
some of them send them to private school
it's it's just this money this is what
it was made for it's energ right and
they're hoarding all of it I mean this
is kind of what made like Europe
stagnate for such a long time is because
most people were lived terrible terrible
lives made no money at all you basically
were I mean imagine if we were back in
the day and we were just working all we
could do is just and there's a lot of
people in America this is this is why
there's so much [__] there's so much
anger and people are so angry and stuff
and they like they want red red meat for
the red pill is because they don't
understand inflation's the silent killer
yeah yeah we're getting like you're
you're getting like I've said this
before like back in the day right we
used to go to Costco as an example you
could fit an entire fi to the top for
$90 back in the early '90s right same
thing I did the other day $600 $800 wow
same [__] thing from 990 to in my
lifetime it went from [__] $80 to $90
to 6
to800 what the [__] is that [__] when
minimum wage was what maybe like what if
you're lucky was probably three to $5 it
even at 15 it doesn't equate at all I
it's you I mean obviously you should you
shouldn't be minimum wage but like but
still it's it's it's this crazy thing we
need those workers too like and that's
the other thing like you know I know
like in the red pill it's like what do
they say like money muscles game frame
or whatever and like you want to make
more money but it's like you do need the
average men running society and we could
not do any of the things we do without
the average men that do the average
salary jobs that start at 45,000 a year
and make 70 in like 70,000 in their 50s
but it's like it you're right where it's
like it's getting harder and harder and
harder for those those men and women to
survive you basically have to earn
$100,000 just to be like starting and
then there's also all the women that so
delusion and but here's the thing I the
one little thing I give the women at
least with this delusion is because deep
down they know like yeah I you need to
have a certain amount of money so we can
even have a [__] family now obviously
if you both will like there's kind of
this whole thing where like let's be
poor but let's have a family it's fine
but like it's still the struggling it's
[__] yeah I actually I think that's
propag Ganda in a way because the 100
G's or or the uh the family because poor
people have more kids yeah that
expensive well it's like like when you
think I have a friend cuz I I I kind of
went down this Rabbit Hole a bit cuz my
my friend um she was just saying you
don't need as much money as you think to
survive but the problem is like we just
have no skills anymore like we're all
idiots she like my friend um she she was
a single mother she had two kids kids
and then um like didn't work out with
the first guy she got remarried and had
another two kids with the next guy and
like he made like 45 whatever like
average earning salary she just said we
lived outside of the city um and we got
chickens and and she was like we just
did the whole homesteading thing and we
just lived really frugally for a really
long time I I I um homeschooled the kids
but it's like we're just too stupid to
do that most of us it's definitely
doable cuz a lot of people do it cuz
like you said I mean if you look at
low-income families they well they have
they have bigger families don't they but
it's it's also because we're also like
bought into this bling lifestyle
everyone's got have the Instagram
lifestyle and buy Frapp Cheetos that's
ruined people as so that's yeah well you
think about it like um I did a wife
School episode where like my like her
name's Auntie Jenny and oh dude she's
awesome yeah yeah yeah she's so funny
she we did an episode where she was like
I could do a week of groceries on 35 lbs
and I was like no that's exactly what
what I said I was like there's no way
but yeah I know she totally did it but
it was like you had was just rice and
beans or something like no no it was I
mean the episode check out wife school
with pearl you know I
don't which which I don't teach by the
way it's like Pearl teaches it no no
like we go through different like
lessons or whatever but yeah um yeah I
know it was like a bunch of different
food but it was just like you had to
know how to like cook it you know what I
mean and and the majority of us like we
don't know how to cook we don't know how
to like do goddamn anything issue of
like the girls that go on say fresh and
fit or the girls that go on your you
know your show and then so what kind of
guy are you looking for it's like well
he's got to make six figures and all
that cuz they they're not their mindset
is not going to be okay well I'm going
to have a family and and we're going to
move outside the city and we're going to
have chickens and we're going like they
would never C it's so funny there is
like a movement of like these fake like
the fake Trad cons where it's like and
it's so funny they're like I just want
to live in a farm and whatever but I'm
like you live in an apartment in like a
big City yeah when are you moving to
this like far like do you and the thing
is I grew up with chickens and ducks
like and I'm not even going to pretend
like like this ain't me you know what I
mean but like like but like like I I I
know how to raise chicken it's a lot of
work like it's really disgusting you got
to like scoop up the poop and I'm like n
you you ladies aren't going to do this
and that's and that's like the bare
minimum like that's not cheap like I've
done the bare minimum farm work like
like I'm like lowest on the totem P I'm
like chicks you guys are not doing this
but the the old idea of just sort of
right we're going to have a family we're
going to sacrifice I mean that's well
certainly for a lot of these these women
and and probably guys as well in these
metropolitan areas that's just gone out
the window like nobody's thinking that
anymore they just they want to be in
they want to be in Miami they want to be
at the boat party they want to do you
know do you know what I'm saying like
what girl really is going to give that
up and that's why they're all competing
for these you know so-called Elite top
TI dudes yeah cuz I even I she was
explaining it to me she's like what do
you really need to survive you you need
food
shelter um and you need wait food
shelter oh and clothes but it's like you
can pass on the like she told me she
felt like she
could uh I forgot what I forgot what she
said each kid cost a month but it was
way less than you think yeah until like
kids school high school doesn't really
matter but we're too yeah but we're too
dumb we don't know how to do
anything like do you know how to sew I
don't my dad used to do my dad used to
do carpentry my dad would build like
bookcases like like proper not from like
like here stuff you know like proper
from original wood and stuff like that I
mean people don't do that stuff anymore
right well it's crazy too because we
have the most information in human
history we can literally go on to
YouTube here and learn literally
anything you can learn how to farm on
[__] YouTube people they like I can
give you like an in-depth Channel
analysis I can do your thumbnails and
your titles but I cannot
sell sorry
guys but it's become this world of
specialist and stuff too as well and CU
like you have to specialize and be like
a niche expert in order to be known for
anything at all and stuff like it's very
hard unless you've already been famous
or like you were a niche expert this why
we tell people if when they when we have
students ask about YouTube We Tell them
like you have to hyper nich into one
coin and hopefully you pick the right
coin because if his goes bad o right but
you pick a good coin it you do really
well and then from there you can be more
General it's the same thing for
everything else you you you hyper na
into into some industry whatever the
[__] it is you get popping and you get
known for that and then you can start
branching out like like Bradley Martin
for an example right he's super super
big cool dude and stuff was all
bodybuilding and working out in the gym
and now is doing like more of a podcast
and becoming more of like an interviewer
and stuff like that and this is what a
lot of people do and stuff like I mean
you could start off like hyper niched
into the into like game or hyper nited
into I mean whatever it is fem cells or
like school and then go into something
else later on have you ever thought
about how like social media changes how
we interact I was like watching like
high schoolers from like like videos of
high schoolers from like 20 years ago
I'm like wow I don't even know what the
world was like without smartphones it's
PR trippy like it like they came for me
in like when I was in eighth grade right
like I mean I I I just remember like I
remember being in Middle School the [__]
was like yeah we didn't have any phones
until like I'd say like maybe the end of
my sixth grade year and the people
started getting flip bones and stuff
like that and then basically it was the
girls who got the phones first and every
guy ran to get a phone because the
moment you got a phone you got to get
their number it was like it was there
was like you know when Instagram first
launch everyone could get super amount
of followers it was that same [__] so I
remember like in my middle school as
soon as you got a phone every girl would
just give you their number and stuff
like you're like [__] yeah
dude and then and then you know but that
was the kind of the advantage so it was
really like girls who like at least in
from what I've seen that like made
everyone want to get phones
basically classic we just spend money
spend money spend youed yeah we're like
Dad but but yeah we've grown softer
because of social media we we've gained
a lot because of social media but we've
also been hurt a lot I mean
relationships I mean we like it it is
kind of weird we shouldn't actually know
like the rich have always been Rich
they've always done the [__] [__] orgies
or whatever the [__] they're doing
degeneracy and good things and bad
things right living in these great
amazing homes but nine times out of 10
you would have never seen it or you
would have seen a little bit and that's
it it but it's being shown in your face
every single [__] day you have these
21 year olds they're showing off they
have all this [__] money and like
dude half half these 21 year olds in
Dubai are [__] brok in their line
or they're selling you a drop Drop
Shipping course and stuff and very few
of them are making money on that and
stuff like that and they're like but you
could Charlie you could right right well
and and the other thing is I was talking
to this um older woman about this um I
think she was like my Uber driver and
she was like she was saying how back in
the day like you would watch the music
awards or whatever and you would realize
like that's not real life the problem
with women now is like we think that
those men are like real life because a
lot of times like you know average
chicks have access to them you know what
or like even like that lifestyle but but
she was like we knew that like okay you
turn on the TV you go to that event but
that's not real but like now it's like
we we almost think this stuff is is real
yeah but that's what's really screwed up
the like the dating Market as well isn't
it you know the whole thing this and R
wrote his essay about this several years
ago talking about the global dating
Marketplace because now like you said
theoretically you know an average to
middling sort of sort of girl if is's
you know relatively cute can get dudes
from like Miami or bloody I don't know
the south of France or whatever like
Dubai dming her and all of that and and
even if she doesn't take up those
opportunities because not every woman's
obviously going to it's going to skew
her perception of her value within the
dating market so you know Joe who works
down the local garage is is suddenly
going to seem less attractive to her you
know because she's looking at these
dudes with like the 12pack and
everything else M so unless you have
like really strong Day game or something
like or night game most some of the the
best chicks are just they're not even in
your area anymore they they're [__]
out they're and I realized too I was
like Wow and even if there is a girl
that maybe like hasn't slept around like
or like is really attractive like all
the things that guys look for I'm like
the line for her is going to be so long
and it almost ruins us having too many
choices yep yeah cuz there was a girl
that went on our show and she was like a
21-year-old like really attractive
virgin and I was like Wow and I was just
thinking from her point of view I'm like
the line is just going to be so long how
do you like pick
one it's sort of like that reverse Meme
and stuff of like that one there's some
chick getting [__] and there's like a
line and there's one dude in a
suit except it's like oh you're trying
to get the application here but I mean
that is C but that is that thing I mean
like uh I can't remember who said this
and stuff but if a woman would just stay
a virgin till 24 [__] you she could get
billionaires she can get all this stuff
and maybe a bit Tad much but you know or
a supermodel you know Waits that long
and stuff at least a millionaire at
least a millionaire or something like
right but you or just but it's that it's
that sort of thing you know it's um and
this all comes down to money scarcity
you know game it's it's there's a so
much [__] and like I really feel like
most guys never would I mean dude the
amount of stuff you got to learn as a
guy and a girl is insane and then on top
of that like it's kind of [__] like
when you're young when you're really
young to learn I
mean to manipulate to [__] up your life
I mean like it's don't it's like don't
be a [__] and we're like we can't do
that I'm buil for this
[__] but I mean like but you know I mean
I I always say this anyone on the 24 is
[__] right but and I don't mean that
in the worst way but it's true but I
mean you got to think a lot to learn
yeah you've got a lot to learn right you
got life lessons to learn and guys are
super stupid I mean we're stupid D and
then there's guys in their 40s are
[__] still but like you know we have
time to kind of grow up and on top of
that I mean yeah if guys could just get
all the py they want they would take it
right away and right off way but for
women like you kind of have the cookie
already and but which are dumb still
yeah well well and I realized too like
we're also like kind of the equivalent
of like porn addicts walking around
because we get so much attention oh you
know what I mean yeah because it's like
we're all like and especially just doing
the show I'm like we all say like the
same exact arguments to each other and
we all just like regurgitate the same
[__] we see on social media and like and
I was just like we're basically just
like these like porn addicted women but
like social media addicted walking
around right yeah cuz they want to be
it's like the magazine right like back
in the day when you're watching like
Sports Illustrated you're like ooh I
want to be like that girl right and that
was like something to attain to because
you have the media making that something
bigger than what it is yeah and now we
have social media doing that Facebook
was the first time right you're like I
know that [__] from high school
does not have that great of a life but
he you know or she right basically
paints a a fantasy and that's now become
like the norm like if you don't lie
about your life on on social media like
you're [__] up well people won't
click on it yeah or even like I remember
I I remember like the last time I went
out with like my volleyball team I was
just like why do we have to film
everything like why do we or even like
you just go to a concert all the like I
went um oh like not being in the moment
well it's like I went to um the the
weekend they they invited like my whole
team to like go like watch the show I I
don't even really know much about the
weekend but the concert was kind of
Satan I was like what on
Earth I was like what on Earth is this
stuff on the stage but it was so crazy
cuz we were in like the part where like
the people that were like invited to it
you know what I'm saying so it was a lot
of like hot chicks like and these are
some I was like wow these are the real
nines and tens I've never really seen
them
before I was like oh okay but yeah and
it was like they were all just on their
phones like recording the whole time and
you know like I I do this video stuff so
sometimes I'm like I do not like want to
be recorded but it's like women were
just out recording everything like all
the time I know men like some men too
but it it is not the same it is not for
business they're not doing it for
anything just purely attention think I
think it's quite hard for for dudes I me
I mean even even for for myself you know
you put stuff on the internet and stuff
like that but to to remind myself to
film stuff and to take photographs I
mean it's just you're just like yeah
whatever whereas you go out with a girl
and she'll be filming everything you
know she'll be getting oh just just take
a different angle of me and they'll be
videoing stuff and putting it on her
social media you know it's just it's
nuts yeah and regardless of the size of
their account girls from very small
accounts to Big accounts you know
they're just all doing it the whole time
yeah and they're like oh you know just
go and kneel in the sewer get that right
angle it's like [__] off you
know Instagram Instagram boyfriends
really bother me every time when we're
out and about because we see here in
Vegas you see this boy it's not it's
nothing bad with a boyfriend or
something or a husband taking a picture
of the wife the problem is is like when
you see these dudes like getting in the
gutter like I mean it's like they're
there're just basically she she dated a
[__] she's like she M just go date a
[__] photographer she [__] doing
and she's just using this good cuz like
half the time you're you're over there
advertising your [__] female mhm so
why you why is she even why is she even
on social media in the first like I
could understand maybe a [__]
Facebook or some [__] right cuz only
Grandma's are on there right now but but
like um but you know why I mean why is
your girl advertising herself so she can
get that bag ditch them and then you
know get too much sauce too much sauce
no
that was like the wheel that was oh my
gosh that was like a red pill and I was
like learning about the stuff I was like
wow we're like why we can't even tell
the difference between wives and mothers
they look the same as single chicks it's
like okay before it's like you kind of
know you move different when you're a
mom and a wife you know you're not going
to you kind of expect all right when
they're young they dress a little
[__] you know you kind of you know
your wife might have worn like a short
skirt back in the day but now it's like
but then it was like when you get
married you cover up now you're the
Virgin Mary you're a nun you don't know
anything but it's
like you can't even tell the difference
like you have Kiki Palmer a Mother
wearing a thong to a concert I'm like
like you know society's bad when you
can't tell the difference and then if
you point that out you're misogynistic
or the bad guy or what about you Pearl
or d d and it's like all right guys I
think this is getting bad like I think
this is not it's like maybe this is like
not the best Direction yeah maybe it's
just it it just always fascinates me
though the amount of power an attractive
young woman has got like and even
economic power it's just incredible like
you could like on Instagram you can
literally like basically you're a hot
chick you're slim you're a hot chick
that that's it 700,000 followers you
know brand deals people flying you out
of places is just amazing and I mean it
for women it must be if you're either
you're in that position that must be
incredibly addictive cuz you you've got
that lifestyle you got those
opportunities but even if you're not but
you're a you know you've got a smaller
account but you're thinking well if I
play it right I could get up there I
mean it's it's no wonder that like
dating is getting screwed it's no wonder
that society's changing right you know
because particularly these young women
they get they get given the keys to the
kingdom don't they if they're attractive
if they're attractive which is great and
they can have fun for for a period of
time but you know then then what happens
you know the metaverse happens and all
of a sudden there 40-year-old dudes
selling you they're AI girls
yeah well it's like we trade a lifetime
of happiness for like 10 years on only
fans it's like I think I think five I
can't remember I'm going to look it up
after the show but only 5% of women are
still practicing like um I think it was
the study was done with hookers but it's
either after the age of 35 or 40 5% are
left oh so they oh so they get rolled
out after at 30 and and then they're
just back well I think it's older than
30 well I don't know what because I was
thinking maybe they'll cuz I'm was
thinking what are they going to do with
us older women like when we're single
childless and like and I was like maybe
they'll legalized prostitution that
would hurt the market the chicks well
but then then I found out um yeah they
yeah men don't obviously want to bang
old chicks and only 5% stay past the age
either 35 or I think it's 40 I think
it's 40 stay where like keep
practicing yeah yeah they're out of work
yeah yeah and then most I mean let's be
for most only fans models don't even
make any money at all it's really like
the 1% of of like these chicks actually
make always managed by men we're so
stupid we can't even sell
sexuality that is the one thing it's
like why are we and you know I know
there's exceptions to every rule but as
a group guys we're dummies like we're
idiots hence the on liners at the
beginning of the
show that always surprised me about the
whole only fans Model Management like
model though you know that Tes were
doing and various other people it's it's
a bit like well can't these girls like
they're the ones with the goods can't
they sell it themselves they're like no
no we do all the back end stuff and
everything it's like well yeah but
surely I mean is it they only work two
hours a day or they'll work they'll work
one day a week cuz that's enough money
and then it's like cool the rest is my
free time and they always say my free
time I think I think even like um like
you said only fans girls I mean
obviously not you know a fraction of
them are making the really big money but
there's opportunity I mean I've
personally met women not only fans but
with small Instagram accounts who are
getting who are doing overseas trips
they're getting flown around by people
like they're in Sugar Arrangements you
know they're getting so not it's not
it's a very soft form of hoing if you
like you know it's not like they're
they're getting large sums of money but
they're certainly getting trips they're
certainly getting advantages off of you
know and these aren't girls with massive
following so it's just incredible the am
of power most most women 80% of women
are hooking for trips they're not even
hooking for money they're they just want
the picture that they're in [__]
Cancun or they're out in Dubai they're
not even getting paid money like you you
you did all that traveling you get a g
congratulations right and like I mean
just I mean and just because somebody in
the chat the chat's kind of going crazy
about this and
stuff obviously there's nothing wrong
with recording yourself with your kids
you should take as many pictures as with
your kids that's beautiful of course but
what we're what we're talking about is
like all these like is if you take a
picture and a little video cool but it
shouldn't be like that should be like 5
seconds or 5 minutes of whatever you're
doing and then you're the phone's away
and you're and you're with the people
you're talking to and stuff right unless
you have like a business or something of
course right no it's kind of weird you
start to see these like moms treat their
kids like
purses like a purse yeah like it's so
weird showing it off yeah it's so weird
it's such a weird phenomenon where I'm
like is this like you don't even seem to
like your kid you just like like the
Instagram picture that's with it but
that's also the tricon thing isn't it
where the tricon's like oh this is this
is look this is true happiness not Dills
not D ban look at me with my kids you
know and it's like well have you seen oh
my God I I trigger the tradcon women so
hard well cuz I just point out and like
I don't claim to be like a a traditional
woman but it's like all these chicks are
like playing pretend I'm like you got
married at 28 and you had two kids
that's feminism like feminism like
because traditional women spend their
primary reproductive years which is like
before the age of 25 like they care
about the family first not themselves
yeah like if you're not married before
255 sorry traditional gone were you a
virgin no and you had two kids it's like
okay like that's feminism I'm not saying
you're a bad person but it's like they
they treat me like I'm like talking
crazy when I'm like I don't think that's
traditional yeah it's like they just got
lucky and cashed out at the top almost
or something like that yeah and I'm like
I'm not I'm not I'm not hating you for
I'm just like I don't think that's but a
lot of girls [__] that up they don't
sell the they don't they don't they
don't get at 28 they're like they're
trying and they're [__] it up cuz
they keep going because I you would know
I know you know a lot of women and stuff
that are like oh I'm trying to find a
husband and but then they start dating
[__] idiots again and then and then
then by the time they're like oh [__]
I'm 32 now uh oh uh oh uh most of them
fumble the most girls fumble that bag
that's the big [__] that's pushed out a
lot is like like if you actually look at
the actual the Cosmopolitan casino it's
named after this [__] whole thing
they pushed they pushed that whole thing
of that lifestyle and they didn't exist
it was [__] it was totally fake I'll
try to find the book later for you guys
but there's a whole book on that whole
thing that they pushed out during the
70s and ' 80s with the Cosmopolitan and
stuff like I mean the Sex in the City
shows and stuff like that's all [__]
like I mean even if you look at
something like um Oprah like Oprah's
like magazine and stuff they they did
calculations if you actually wanted to
live the Oprah lifestyle it was like you
have you had to be wasting $260,000 a
year to do all the stuff that's being
shown on there and so it's it's all
[__] a grift and stuff like that it
but it is what it is you know this is
why like at the end of day you have to
choose what you want for your life yeah
I think that's and it makes sense when
they're like red pill guys like don't
give advice because like every guy has
to like there's pros and cons to every
decision I know some guys do but like I
understand why there others at least a
sector that don't because every guy kind
of has to make a decision for himself
they well they they do and they have to
decide what kind of Lifestyle do you
want and and I mean I think one of the
issues I've got with the trcom people is
that they're so preachy about it you
know they're like oh if you're not if
you're not you know you're a degenerate
and all this kind of stuff and it's like
well I I mean it's Different Strokes for
different folks right and it's it's sort
of like um if if you want to live that
lifestyle that's absolutely fine but
equally you've got to look at the
divorce rate you've got to look at the
infidelity rate you've got to look at I
mean Rich Cooper recently was was
tweeting about how much happiness is
there in even in relationships that that
remain together so like you've got to
look at the reality of the situation
here and think well do I actually want
to do that route or am I just doing that
because you know society's tell the
incentives in line to be able to do that
in a positive way like a lot of times
the incentives are just so out of whack
to Mak zero sense well and even if we
take out the numbers the stats cuz the
tradcons will always manipulate some
stat they'll be like well rich men are
married I'm like yeah cuz [__] love
rich
men and like the guys then make more
money because they're like oh [__] I got
all these kids like I don't think he's
taking home more cash like and um but
it's like okay is our reputation as
wives good like let's just ask ourselves
this like really across the board are
like are men saying yes Western women
you are amazing wives like and like I
think a lot of us we really got to be
honest with ourselves like most of us
were not raised to be wise even if you
came from a two parent home your mom
most likely did not teach you to obey
your father which is the number one
thing you're supposed to do as a wife
you're supposed to obey most women have
not been taught that most of us have no
real skills right none of none of us
really can cook from scratch n of us are
that neat like I think most women
nowadays were messier than the men we
need to put Pearl's face on an O Bay
shirt like and then they'll they'll come
at me and be like Pearl are you this
like Trad con I'm like no sorry I wish I
was but like it's like you know we do
the best we can but it's like I I don't
think we can improve if we can't even
say hey this is the ideal the ideal is
you know but it's funny cuz men
understand the ideal they're like yeah
that jacked guy with
money like that that runs the company
that's the ideal but as women we can't
say okay the virgin women that marry
rich men young I think they're winning
or pick a winner young because you don't
have good Idols is it because you don't
have good idols and stff the old the old
jealous well I think it's because like
we we interpret the so if like if I say
hey I think I'm 26 so if I say a 22
year-old woman is hotter than me
yep then then therefore I need to be
offended because like you know Tate said
he I think he had a clip that said a 26
year I'd rather date a 19-year-old than
a 26y old or more something like that
and I was like I'd agree like and Z me
[__] teenagers yeah no but I was I was
even thinking about myself I'm like yeah
I was probably better at 19 sorry like
you know like but it's like we can't
live in reality because then it makes us
look bad because most women look bad in
some way well but then you get the sort
of self-defining no I'm a queen you know
and it's some girl and she's very
overweight and all rest of it you know
we see it on these shows all the time
don't we and it's yeah but then if you
say yeah I'm an average chick they're
like you hate yourself I'm like I don't
think that's it it's you know yes Queen
you're a
10 but I just I just like to live in
reality like I don't understand why as
women we can't just like say this is the
ideal that virgin that weighted the hot
chick the model there like you know
Megan Fox in her prime yeah you know
like maybe without the being a [__] but
like you know
but like that's that would be the ideal
but it's like no no lizo is the ideal
like we just was it you was it you or I
forgot who said this and stuff but when
you're like he like all right if if
they're if they love lizo so much and
said say oh you look just like lizo
yeah see how offended they get like they
like they're always biging up a bunch of
these people and stuff but but then you
tell them you're like they're you're you
look like them and they why they get
offended yeah well and you ask and you
ask why and I think it goes back to
we're dummy
[Laughter]
we're idiots like I genuinely and I
don't even say this I've just like come
to this conclusion I'm like I think men
are just Superior like I know and I know
people think I'm like mean but I was
like I can't think of one thing we're
better at as a group I'm like we are
more likely to kill infants and elderly
think about that the one thing we're
supposed to be good at the not the top
melin chefs are men it's like men if you
put a dollar at the end of it if you put
a dollar and said be like the most
nurturing person men would just figure
out how to do it better than us like
like men you know they just they just
figure it out so do you I think I've
seen you talk about this somewhere but I
mean what what's your view on the
passport Bros then do you think that's
fair enough under the circumstances yeah
I mean well you know one part of me is
like well if she's not loyal to her
country how loyal is she going to
be someone said that I thought really
bad at everything yeah but but you know
at the same I mean there's pros and cons
to it I've heard some guys say if you
bring her back then you're going to be
in the same problem you know cuz now
she's going to be this commodity but I I
also say you know fair enough if
anything we should kind of look at those
countries that they're going to and say
what can we learn from them yeah like
you know I heard the Asian chicks are
like the first picked on dating apps and
I'm like well I mean we could probably
learn something they're probably more
submissive than us you know they're
probably thinner okay we could probably
learn something there but women like we
don't learn we just
whine yeah it's it's God
damn like yeah it's it's just it's just
a kind of crazy thing what's going on
with the world and stuff like that I
mean it's just to go back to the idols
and stuff I mean like they were pushing
Kim Kardashian forever and stuff and
this where a lot of girls grew up with
um I mean cuz like you know me and
Charlie started demographics and stuff
and I mean pretty much like I mean half
of the like like I'm right in the middle
of the Millennials right so I was like
91 right I think the youngest the
youngest Millennial right now is like 25
oh I think it's me yeah how old I'm 26
you're right on yeah so 26 25 is the
youngest Millennial right there right
and you got to think the other half of
the millennial girls if they've already
[__] their lives up they're [__]
already they're all cat food women so
what's going on is all the top
Millennial guys are basically stealing
the extra chicks I mean I mean Zumer
chicks and then on top of that if you
look at most other countries right if
you're if if your passport Brewing we're
essentially cucking out other dudes in
other countries and taking their chicks
and their it is what it is but you know
well and honestly it's going downhill
across the board like I mean I IDE deal
with so many International like people
on the podcast and like my my one
producer is from Nigeria my other's from
Zimbabwe and they'll they'll tell me
like the women are going downhill too
we're having the same issues it's just
like a generation delayed so yeah yeah
social media is ruining all of us right
CU cuz we're dummies I think Russia
Russia well cu the war and stuff the
Ukraine
too wow but um yeah there's a lot of I
mean dude there just I mean not to talk
too much about that but like d all the
guys are sending to the slaughter over
there it's insane oh M it's insane it
was yeah it was it was crazy actually
because last year we were in Poland and
obviously a lot of refugees female
refugees had come over to Poland from
from Ukraine and we were definitely it
was funny cuz tusk was saying you know
we talked to girls not you know we we'd
meet different girls like Polish women
whatever it wasn't you know but we would
sometimes meet girls who'd come over
because of the war and like Tusk would
say oh I got this girl's Instagram but
she's got this like weird it looks like
this weird burner Instagram account
that's not her real one do you know what
I mean and we she's married ex exactly
you know it's it's a really and we were
like what a sad State of Affairs you
know even Eastern European women like
God we can't even be loyal well yeah you
know and like this is like you know how
I came to this conclusion I was trying
to think of anything we were better at
and I couldn't find
anything I mean what was it the classic
The Village girl is dead she doesn't
exist or not really unless she has a
very strong father with a grip on her
but yeah it's it's it's kind of crazy
and I mean what have you experienc in in
Japan Charlie cuz it's that is a very
different world do you live in Japan
yeah for about 10 years oh wow cool but
in terms of what do you mean in terms of
like I guess like how the cuz like this
is I think we uh we said this on your
stream earlier today too and stuff I
think Pearl asses was like what's going
down there too cuz you have really good
women there right but the birth rate is
dog [__] right it's very bad there it
goes down to basically work culture
right A lot of the time which is because
they've adopted a lot of Western work
culture because it makes the most money
and also they these countries have also
worked with the United States been
formed after World War II to the global
economy now all of a sudden instead of
having just one you know husband U
basically working like a dog because
they work really really hard there um
and then the woman would be able to stay
home take care of the kids they have the
nuclear family all as well right now
both of them have to do it right and
then you get the same problem which is
you have some women who are like I'm
going to be a career woman until I'm 38
then I'm going to have kids oops I can't
have kids right that kind of thing so
it's the same problem it's actually
becoming more pervasive around the world
but because that culture I would say h
is a little bit more of a shock to it
because it went from one extreme to
another right um that I think has
shocked and of course there's other uh
factors as well but I would say um when
you look at daily life with people
that's like one of the biggest because
uh a lot of people I mean you said it
before right they just don't have any
time at the end of the day to be like
okay now I'm actually going to devote
myself to family do you think that's
because like don't they have like a [__]
ton of debt oh yeah the country does
people do as well but I mean it's the
same thing as here it's like you're
promoted to take on debt in order to try
to right but I was just wondering cuz I
I I think it was years ago I I could be
wrong but I thought like they were
leading in debt or like at least like
one of the like biggest debt and I was
wondering if somehow like that transfers
on to the people where they're most of
the debt most of the debts owed to
themselves so it's kind of like you they
created it in Japan specifically yeah
like you're printing your own currency
to buy your own debt which is just
basically a way to finance and print
printing money and stuff right so does
that go to inflation yeah it's similar
to what the United States does but uh a
little bit more crazy so so Japan is the
first nation to lead this charge because
basic so so there's a thing we teach in
crypto and stuff we teach and it's it's
a real it's a it's a red pill truth
everything's a Ponzi everything's
everything's finite it isn't going to
last forever right you are going to die
I'm going to die right right sad but I
mean but everything everything ends
right I mean um the Roman Empire gone
Greek gone I mean the [__]
Babylonians gone and stuff like you know
aliens dead you know maybe Mayan's gone
right oh Tex but um but if you look at
this what's going on is the the the in
terms of money the underlying thing that
that powers everything the bottom of the
pyr what holds the the the real [__]
denominator right there of everything is
is your nation growing in population uh
period that's that's all that at the end
of the day if you if the average couple
in America is having three [__] kids
one to replace you your husband and one
for the economy the econom is like this
it's [__] straight up like this this
is why like I mean people like George
gamon and stuff like they're investing
into um U what's called Colombia it's
one of the few Latin American countries
with a good with a good demographic
because they're actually having kids
down there that's why people AR
investing money right now Mexico's
demographics are good for the next 20 30
years so people are putting money there
it's the same thing in the Philippines
they're so basically people are buying
the Phil buying to the Philippines
investing and they're going to [__]
exit in the next 20 years out of out of
Philippines because then they're they're
going into population decline Japan was
the first nation to have a they had a
big baby boom and what end up happening
is that they're the first to kind of the
population starty of going down but so
what they're doing is they're using
their own debt which Japan has done this
in the past where it's called a jubilee
where they say I forgive all their the
debt that they can forgive right and
they're going to do that probably at
some point but this is why but since
they were the first nation to do it
happened to them they went into
Automation and they're probably going to
be the first country to kind of survive
so everyone's kind of looking at Japan
is like what Happ if you kind of look at
what they did right if you watch the
documentary the princes of the end they
basically made a deal with the the bank
of international settlements which is
the world's Central Bank I Amy I am yeah
it's like a deal with the devil they
were just like hey we have a pretty good
economy going in the 80s right and
they're like well we want to keep it
going but you know we'll have Financial
Warfare happening between Western
countries and Japan if they smoke
everybody so instead why don't you guys
just like sell off a lot of your your
good land a lot of your good assets kind
of bastardize your currency and we'll
let you into the club you always be in
the top five right and you'll make
enough money but right you have to like
sell off half your country this is
why you know I'm gonna you know I'm
going to take credit all the
tradcons have been bringing this up
again and and I am solop listic or
whatever as a woman so I'm just taking
credit for
that yeah whatever it
is but that that's what's going on there
so this is a [__] this is a really
[__] up stat right here the J the
Japanese economy in terms of so GDP
growth which is like the it's like the
average income of the country basically
right it's been the same since 1994 wow
it's 2023 and why is that that's exactly
the year that the bank well it was like
1987 to 1994 that 7 years period was
when they basically did that so why are
people having kids in Columbia then and
not it plac there there's a lot of
moving there um they've kind of fixed a
lot of things down there like it's
because there's aot basically what ends
up happening is just basically um
they've managed to fix a lot it's not
perfect they'll manag to fix a lot of
things there's been a lot of
reinvestment and there's a lot of money
flowing there so people are just you
know they locals are having money from
westerners coming there and and there
starting to be jobs right I mean like
Columbia is a great place I mean you've
been to Columbia it's [__] awesome
yeah yeah I love it but you know Argent
Argentina's another one it could be but
it's running by [__] Nazis but like
Argentina's like it's literally
demographically and if you actually look
at it in terms of its actual land it's
it should be a [__] Powerhouse it has
some it has some of the best screwed
though AR they the economy screwed over
yeah because what ends up happening is
because our Germans that's what it is I
mean let's be for real like there a lot
of evil [__] happened down in Germany
what they do is they they get their
currency good and what they start doing
they start printing the money and then
they they've they've hyperinflated like
three four times in history already like
the tequila crisis almost took out took
them out again and stuff like I mean
it's it's insane what ends up happening
Nigeria has the highest birth rate yeah
it's it's a couple Latin American
countries schemes like mostly look so
basically um South Korea has the lowest
yep yep wow I didn't expect that they're
doing real bad
63 I thought Asia was like like well no
they're top they're ta most of Asia is
is it's going down depends on how you
cuz like a uh what do you call it India
and as well as China that EXC I've never
counted India as like Asian stuff but it
depends on yeah how you look yeah just
what's your perspective for Mexico
though in terms of say feminism and
westernization creeping in do you think
it's it's
it it it's still much cheeso right now
we we've got probably like 20 years
before it goes to [__] probably yeah
because because I mean I I was in Mexico
City like in January I've been to Mexico
a few times and we think it's great from
a perspective of like you know from
London but but an old schooler would be
like what the [__] going on these
[__] why these [__] have [__]
naked and these themselves out I mean
it's like I I went in the '90s it wasn't
like that at most a girl was wearing
some booty tight jeans at [__] most
and that was crazy you know what I I
kind of notice like Trends and it seems
like the the 40 to 60-ish year old women
are just like the the shitty wives like
they got yeah like they got yeah yeah so
like this is kind of how I categorize it
40 to 60y old women like they got
married and maybe they're not too much
of [__] but they're pretty like
miserable wives like they kind of nagged
for a lifetime didn't know beg that was
like the first wave of propaganda that
kind of just like um and they're living
through their daughters yeah yeah well
the and the generation above them like
60 to
75 um and by the way the 40 to 60y old
women those are the ones that got
divorced yes and the 60 to 75 they
separated M A lot of them separated but
they didn't divorce they they actually
stuck it out they stayed married but
they really weren't it seems like when I
when I've interviewed women of all ages
it seems like the 80 to 100 year old
women are the only ones with like the
obey your husband mindset where the
other ones will push back under 60 and
and it's kind of 5050 with the 60 to 75y
old these are just the trends I
see yeah I mean I can see that I mean
this is why like I mean basically the
other the second I mean developing
nations they're just a cycle a
generational cycle behind us that's it
but you got to you'd have to go this is
why in Africa I mean maybe in Africa
maybe they're like a cycle and a half
but because of smart like it took I I
forgot how long it took it took like a
hundred years and stuff to get like
telephone wires and all this stuff it's
done there it took what like 30 years to
get internet across the world and it
took and then phones ended up like
smartphones ended up taking like 10 15
years as soon as your smartphones came
out within 2 three years you ended up
having them all over Africa like one of
the biggest Curr CES in the world is
basically internet phone
minutes in Africa it's it's become
essentially a cryptocurrency where
they're trading SIM cards with like hey
I have I have international calling on
here I've got 25 minutes damn son [__]
I'll trade it for a donkey you know what
and that's what what's going on but
Africa's got the I mean so basically
like Africa's got the highest growth
rate right now in terms of population
then I would say it would probably be
some parts of Latin America that's
starting to fade real quick actually so
and then we have um we have basically
all of Asia's tapped out already in
terms of like they're at the peak right
now and what what that means is they
have they have a bunch of Millennials
and they're going to be like all right
like the Philippines the
Philippines are good for about 25 years
and then what's happening is that the
the Millennials of the Filipinos and
stuff they're not having kids at the
same rate so they're going to have
they're going to start doing bad in
about 25 years but they're doing good
now they're going to do really well
right now okay and you know what's crazy
it I always thought like birth control
was the root of everything but it
actually started like the birth gr
started started declining in well
actually the 1800s but it started
actually like more I guess dramatically
declining in the 20s like the Roaring
20s because what would happen was women
that was the first time before the 20s
you talking about the flappers what
flapper girls oh yeah before before the
20s they would go from their dad's house
to their husbands there was no in
between the 20s was the first time women
would like get their own apartment maybe
work and it seems to be like to me I I
think like women spend our primary
reproductive years working was
like I don't want to say just but also a
big like impact in addition to birth
control because like we can have a
cultural shift but that doesn't change
biology I mean it's going from
agricultural to Industrial Age I mean
that's you don't you don't need as many
kids you don't you don't I mean like if
we all lived on farms we like why
wouldn't we have eight kids to help
around to to play maybe or something
maybe slightly double Advocate but if
the if say the elites or whoever but you
know they they see us as the the tax
slaves and everything else wouldn't it
wouldn't it behove them to get everyone
to have more kids because then the
economies would do really well and then
they take more cash off the top so you
know what I'm saying now this is just
Theory to Me Maybe Charlie has a
different answer on this but to me it
seems that we've hit a certain level of
technology and automation that you don't
need as many people for them because
they can they've already can create
enough and so now it's more about
controlling it yes and getting it down
well that's yeah that's a good point
actually AI obviously we know how many
jobs that [__] is dangerous that [__] is
dangerous you guys sometimes I think AI
will just replace women's jobs and then
boom we'll be back at
home well yeah cuz we're like dummies
like men will figure something
out like you still need the men to do
like the physical labor like bu like
they can't out like they can't AI
Plumbing electricity but in 40 years
maybe but not now like we we still have
a good like yeah any anything pH you
cannot like these Ma can't but a lot of
like white white callar is going to get
[__] in the next 10 years wow well
yeah it's but it's the people who are
the most skilled yes right that will
basically they'll be able to scale their
skill and then the lower skilled people
essentially get cut out and they'll have
to learn how to use AI as that skill and
if they don't then you know so it is a
building up for the people on the lower
end as well but they have to lean into
the new technology and there's like a
really really [__] up thing that I
like that this is just a speculation on
this has to do with IQ right where
they're saying like every time we have
these technological jumps there's like a
bare minimum of an IQ where you can be
above like where you know you don't have
if you get your job taken away you and
then you you're [__] right where
people there's some there's like a truck
there's really smart truck drivers like
some truck drivers lose it and then they
end up running a whole Fleet digitally
or they end up just converting into
something else and doing a lot of money
well what happens is as technology keeps
getting more and more Advance it's like
the the the minimum level of IQ in order
to succeed
keeps going higher that it starts
affecting larger portions of the
population because not everyone's going
to be like most people are at the
average like if you have if you're above
a 100 you're you're not Norm you're not
normal I mean you're kind of above
normal but I mean it what is it the
military doesn't take anyone under 70 IQ
for a reason because it's like they're
going to they're going to [__] kill
everybody by accident you know and
that's kind of the weird [__] that's
happening where like the the the I mean
that also could be what's going on too
is that I mean females don't have to
like do this because they just got to
get [__] I mean you know but like it
could be this whole thing where like the
IQ keeps rising and Rising that's also
another thing where like those guys are
the ones making money then they get to
breed which then ends up making the race
smarter well and well the IQ of the
whole population is declining look
because women women ruined the industry
really like this is no this is so true
this is like like I'm I'm going to
explain this so in the 80s basically
women like went into education like it
used to be a male dominated field then
women came in and we're like oh let's
make it fair and equal and they like it
used to be that you would um like have
standardized tests so we would study you
would take a standardized test women
made it more subjective so
projects homework all that [__] yeah
and then you see IQ I mean it's been
dropping for a hundred years but it
dropped a lot quicker since the 80s test
scores um and it's so funny because now
we have a teacher and a teacher Aid and
they literally can't teach as well as
one man like two women can't do the job
that one man used to do or
dummies well now they don't like if you
if you don't pass a test they like well
we'll find a way and then still put you
through so crazy I don't know my
multiplication tables swear to God I
always got the smartphon yeah I know but
like how did I make it this old and I
don't know I can like I can do up to
like six I can't do sevens and eights I
like I have
to like I was like how did I how did I
keep going in school yeah yeah I just
always told the teacher I was like yeah
I'll just use the calculator they're
like you're not always going to have a
calculator
I'm pretty sure I
will that's when they'd be like you're
not going to be able to get away with
this in college and it was like me in
college I'm like like I'm sleeping in
class it's true though in a way isn't it
as the technology improves do we really
need to have the same recall do we
really need to CU like now you can just
look everything up on yeah but then I
think that's the problem though is
you're so relying on like the top people
to run all that stuff and they have more
control m well then it's like okay well
what's your what are you what do you
want to use that brain power for after
that then right like a lot of it is
creativity I think yes yeah because the
more creative you are the more you can
use those Technologies yeah yeah
absolutely yeah like it's crazy I get
paid to just like tweet like this is
what Humanity has evolved
to perance you may like my grandma and I
was thinking about this I'm like my
grandma had 13 children my grandma knew
how to sew she knew how to like you know
I I still cook my grandma's like
homemade recipe that this is like I can
cook a few things you know what I mean
like these cookies from scratch but like
my grandma like made up this recipe and
I was just thinking I'm like wow well
she wasn't distracted by you know the
smartphones or the devices too she had
the time to be like okay I was there's
nothing to do right now tonight I'm
going to do this it's going to be great
yeah and I was just thinking I'm like
I'm her granddaughter and I
tweet and I'm like this is how humanity
is going I'm gonna do it you know I get
paid to do it so it's just like you know
don't don't hate the play or hate the
game but I was I was thinking about this
I'm like wow this is how humanity is
like it is incredible isn't it really
where we've got to with all of this
stuff you know it's just like it's a
bizarre sort of like reality that we're
all in now of this you know just being
on these platforms and just doing this
stuff you know and even watching like
Amish women like I'll watch videos and I
grew up um we would get our furniture
from the Amish so I've actually like you
know kind of talked to a decent amount
of them
and it's so crazy what they do in a day
I could not I couldn't accomplish in a
week they like get up at the crack of
dawn they do all the cow stuff all the
and I'm like wow they like sew their
clothes they I'm like wow they're
absolutely smarter than us yeah but
that's the problem isn't it because
because most most people are not going
to I'm not saying you should become AR
anyone should become armish but most
people aren't going to want anything
approximating that lifestyle are they
cuz they want to be on the yacht they
want to be on the yacht with with Drake
in Miami right you know yeah he hasn't
invited me which is so
crazy so crazy yeah but you know it's
like everyone wants this lifestyle that
we see portrayed on Instagram and
everything else and it's like I I don't
know I I don't know I don't think
there's any going back from this is
there really you know yeah we just get
more and more dable we get more and more
cardi beer ified until the world blows
up right it's like uh what do you call
it uh Pandora's box right once you go
down that route it's just going to kind
of
go to its ultimate conclusion I think it
was n back in like the mid 1800s a
German philosopher and uh different he
did a bunch of different stuffs he
basically said this we're going towards
a uh ultimate Tech technological Society
where um you have no connection with
nature anymore so in order to kind of go
back to that like you were saying before
go back and you know kill some chickens
right oh my God they they have feelings
you know all that stuff but you have to
do that in order to have a balanced life
and get out of
the [__] because it's like you have
to go to one extreme because we're
already in one extreme well maybe the
devil will like come and kill us all
like sometimes I think I'm like maybe
we're just like going towards the end of
time I really I really I was thinking
about this have you ever thought about
how the cuz the enlightenment period was
just basically like ruining the natural
order of the world you know I mean this
is what you know coming arguably coming
out of the Dark Ages light stuff
arguably arguably but but I was thinking
about I'm like is the Constitution
woke in what way wait what way think
about it we all
have I'm trying to remember the exact
phrasing of the con how does the
Constitution start we'd have to pull it
up okay but but it says like every man
like has rights or whatever created
equal or created oh yeah that was it
we're all created equal are we created
equal no isn't that kind of ruining the
natural order where it's like weaker men
submit to Stronger men and you actually
aren't supposed to have the same rights
because when you think about it you have
to have like in order to have the same
rights you have have to have the same
responsibilities right when it goes back
down to an ideal right they what they're
describing as an ideal not necessarily
reality which is
woke it is today it is yeah inter
depends on how you interpret it well
it's it's kind of it's kind of a rabit
do you take it you take it
metaphorically how much I it's still
it's still the best thing that we have
right now but it's a sort of thing we're
like is it yeah it is I mean it really
is I mean there's we we've succeeded
unbelievably there's no n the world will
not be the way it is I mean [__] like
the world would be in a [__] [__] are
we in the are we in the best time to be
alive we're in one of the most
convenient times to be alive whether
it's the best time to be alive or not
you decide you know there's been time
periods where everyone would get a piece
of land everyone would get a house yeah
and then the Mongol come everybody can
everybody can is why do they tell you
cuz that's kind of what they always say
like in this time period it was E I
don't know I'm not like saying that this
is the answer but I'm like was it I mean
if we're just trying to be if we're
trying to be a th% skeptical oh you
don't have time machine so maybe like
all hisory all that history was a lie
but usually if you look at recorded
history all human history really there
really is a huge vein of like historians
where all human history is war that's
what that's when we always like this war
this people conquer this different
opportunities at different times I mean
if you look at what we have now right
you go to the crypto [__] and you're
like holy [__] I can make in well not
infinite amounts of money but I can
print my own money right we've never had
that ability in human history before all
the kings and queens they all basically
said no no no we don't want you to
control the money we're going to control
the money don't worry about it now that
people start controlling a form of money
right it scares the [__] out of them so
I think it's up to the individual do we
want do you want you know all of that if
that's what you want then go and work
for it you know but people don't want to
[__] work anymore I mean quality of
life has vastly improved because people
today have more than some of the richest
people did like 200 years ago you know
but but but but we've let some social
[__] get out of out of out of [__]
order you know I was just thinking about
this I was walking around in London okay
and I live I live in um the hood in
London a little bit yeah no not not
actually but it's um and I live in this
apartment building and I was just
thinking about how and there's a lot of
families in this apartment building and
that like there's a bunch of buildings
next to each other and I was like
everyone's living in these like boxes
we're just like living in these boxes
next to each other where I was like
there's been times in history where
literally everyone would get a piece of
like I think it they were like surfs or
something and I'm butchering no it was
more it was more indentured servitudes
and like
even you argue that today you can arue
that but if you even go to the Roman
times right the reason the Roman Empire
fell is because literally and and they
could use slaves instead of real people
to have jobs and stuff and most people
didn't have land the rich ended up
buying all the land up I mean this is
just like the same human we're going
through the same [__] human CC
opportunity Arbitrage yeah so I don't
know I just I think about these things
and I'm like are we really
free are we really it's a person person
but how we ever been free cuz before
before we were [__] let's just say
when if we go back if we're we're doing
this [__] experiment we go all the
way back we go to caveman times right
we're just trying to survive are we and
I wonder if a caveman and night like are
we really free every time like like my
brother could die at any any time or my
or my mother or my kid could die at any
time what I would think
though what I'm thinking though like
with the Equal Rights or whatever I was
thinking about this I'm like wait so
basically in the caveman days like these
cavemen would build the society or
whatever tribal Hunter yeah yeah yeah
but then I'm like they wouldn't say
everyone's got equal rights in this
Society no no no but but they all have
different organizations and it's like
yeah I don't know we taking else to the
environment in the in the overall I mean
it's like shortened lifespan I think we
we talked about this earlier well was it
a shorten lifespan probably go invent a
time machine tell me but but like
seriously but there is points in times
historically they've said yeah some
people have only lived at 27 during
Roman times during the bad times during
the like during the crisis the plagues
PL not just the plagues but there's like
there's these Cycles where like life
expectancy goes to [__] like really
badly and then it only recovers to 40
and then if you're wealthy maybe you
could live or you just got these
gangster genic we all we all know' heard
of people that they smoke cigarettes
[__] two packs of a day for all their
life they live to be [__] 90 and
there's some some people they smoke one
pack for a week and they catch [__]
AIDS you know like you know what I'm
saying like it's it's it's genetic and
stuff but there's people with these god
tier genetics and stuff for like some
stuff like I mean you have people like
[__] Ronnie Coleman and stuff dude
basically almost wins an Olympia no
steroids gets on steroids wi goes eight
times you know and you have some people
like they could put all the steroids in
their body and look like dog [__] you
know and there there's there's all that
there and stuff so it's I mean I don't
know I mean I don't know I wish I could
I wish I could tell you cuz like I mean
depending like we got so this this this
whole Android 19 co co shot crap like it
shook so many people even me too like it
shook everyone up that we have to we
we're doubting everything now completely
like government's talking about [__]
aliens now what the [__] are we doing
right now I think I think they did that
to see how stupid we are yeah of course
they're like how stupid is the
population but you think they would know
already they're like we have these girls
like doing the talking things on Tik Tok
they like remember the [__] Chinese
pushing the [__] nightquil
challenge do you think the Earth is
round or flat don't ask me this man I'm
it's flat as a pancake man flat as a
pancake no it's actually a hexad it's a
cube it's a cube I think it's Hol I
think it's Hollow and there's another
there's another there's a race of Elites
living in no I'm saying we could try the
floor I mean okay so the whole the whole
thing with like now if I'm understanding
there's like two sides of these Flat
Earth one that the the moon thing is
just a pro it's [__] it's just it's
up in the atmosphere it's not actually
in space and it's reflecting you know
how like the moon doesn't move or some
[__] you could God damn it here we go um
that that's actually showing all the
real continents on the planet right like
we're a flat surface and what's going on
is like supposedly there's some ice wall
like we're being blocked around and
there's actually all these other nations
out it's sort of like we're [__] like
really if you really think about let
like we're on Attack on Titan and we're
on the [__] Island and there's all
these outside Nations that basically
have like these guys are like Mega
retards that could actually kill us all
so we put them into this island like if
you my anime D will know what this is
but like there's a whole anime on that
you think the Earth is flat legitimately
yeah there's a chance I don't think so
but I mean but if if we're going off of
[__] religion and we're going off all
this I'm not saying it's zero I'm not
saying it's zero I don't think it's very
high I think we're Round And We There is
space and [__] but like there's a chance
like the thing is you know why I say a
chance say lie about everything [__]
everything like there probably was
Nephilim Giants and [__] and like these
the giants made it with the with I mean
[__] Angels made it with the [__]
women and stuff of course betray us U
with and then [__] gave birth to the
Giants and the Giants were ruling over
Babylon and all this crap and then
there's [__] whole things about is
Atlantis real no well they're they're
proving that maybe it was actually an
Africa and they just got it just it got
flooded out and [__] there there's yeah
it's like you know where like the uh uh
there's like okay so uh okay in Africa
you know like that round part right
there on Africa there's if if you go
right there in the center of the desert
there's like it it's shown that like it
looks like there was [__] huge tidle
waves that destroyed something and
there's kind of like this weird thing
like a pattern in the Rocks that's kind
of like waved out yeah there's that
could have been Atlantis and it makes
and it makes sense and stuff cuz like
the Egyptians I mean if you the the
earliest account accounts of Atlantis
came from the Egyptians right and it was
like high priest that kept these stories
and stuff like that so it could have
been yeah I mean like it could have been
the atlanteans that gave a lot of the
information to the beginning societies
of that it could have been the
atlanteans that escaped that gave that's
that that gave this extra information to
people on the Nile that created the
Egyptian kings who were black by the way
who are black then eventually became
more mixed raced and stuff just through
over time and stuff like that it just
there's all kind of tons and tons and
there's tons and tons of [__] you guys
you know yeah yeah but do you think it's
a problem that now look ma is in the
chat just one second DCC the world is
not it's okay no the whole thing is it's
a thought experiment it's a thought
experiment because look but like I'm in
crypto I've seen the impossible happen
I've seen I cannot discount anything SE
the earth flat out yeah 10,000 10,000
I've seen 10,000 x man hex ain't dying
but like
um but like you have you these are like
as an e like I'm a fundamental analysis
guy so I have to like I have all these
like imagine like as an example like I
have to have like if this is what I'm
this is my main thing that's driving me
forward I have to be able to
simultaneously run different simulations
in my brain and then be able to like see
okay maybe this this is now the new the
new the world's changed now it's going
this way now and it's sort of like we're
we're in Multiverse we can go into these
different multiverses and we have all
these choices and this pushes in this
direction so like I have to I have to
have a bunch of wh ifs in scenarios like
what like this is a big wh if right now
like I told this to a lot of guys inside
the crypto minds and meet up if you
didn't go damn that's sad yeah but big
sad but I told this to people like 24
like we're we're doing really well we
got the Bitcoin happing the the [__]
election they're not going to crash the
economy during a [__] election unless
they want [__] like Marshal Strife
right which they might another crisis to
take advantage of change your money but
there's a 20% 30% chance as we get
closer we'll know more because you can
only really tell a year in crypto maybe
in equities a little more with macro but
uh because crypto moves so much but you
know right now we can tell 24 is going
to be a really good year and what's
going to happen is there's a good chance
that if Trump wins it doesn't matter who
wins yeah and as soon as that that year
ticks over to January and uh January
2025 equities and all this [__] crashes
and that way they can give these
stimulus checks out for that that have
to give that a 20 30% chance and the and
these are things that I that's why if
we're in big profits in 24 take some
[__] profits yep right and but people
a lot of people don't think because they
what they happens to them is they just
stay no this is what's going to happen
and me I I've got to me and Charlie have
to be flexible we got to be able to like
if we see some [__] major piece of
information like like we had one Outlook
in in 2021 and then the FED increased
rates in January and we're like [__] me
and Charlie like damn it we're going
down now 100% now [__] and we told guys
to start selling and it was a smart move
because
it was over yeah yeah but that but like
that was a paradigm shift most people
couldn't do cuz I N you could 95% of the
[__] influence it's going to keep
going we're going for a third pump we're
repumping back up we're having a triple
top triple top you guys they're afraid
to piss off people right because people
are pretty linear they're like okay this
is the case so this must be the the
result that happens after that where
like you said that if this then that
scenario it's a lot more fluid than that
and so when the narrative shifts they're
like you lied to me so you no the
there's Dynamics here it's like weather
right it changes you got to be open to
different possibilities at the same time
and and and almost hold simultaneous
views or at least consider simultaneous
views in your mind the whole time and be
sort of nimble in your thinking because
otherwise you get caught out I I like I
literally get caught at home all the
time like ky's Miguel yeah like I'm
literally just eating and I just Zone
the [__] out because I'm thinking about
this and this it's like bro you're not
eating oh yeah my bad bro but this is
what you have to think about and stuff
like that and then like and but this the
other beautiful thing is like like we
like we we kind of put this like if you
look at the crypto mindset logo and
stuff it's like half a brain one side's
all math the other sides it's like
colors right I'm the color side of the
brain I'm thinking about like what are
the possibilities what's this and stuff
the emotional side right Charlie's The
Logical side which is basically the
graphs the numbers like because
sometimes I can't find the information
what's going on in the market but the
chart's saying it or sometimes the
chart's saying this and we like bro we
just heard all this stuff from these
guys right and then there's the brackish
water right between there it gets real
interesting and this is the problem is
like you like why me and Charlie have
worked so well is cuz you know we're
like we're you know you know we're shake
and bake baby you know like is you know
peanut butter and Jay is because Mo most
guys end up starting businesses with
people that are just like them and [__]
you guys want to butt heads because if I
was a if I was a chart guy and Charlie's
a CH guy we'd be arguing every [__]
day Charlie I'm [__] telling you he's
going to do this and but like I'm able
to like think about this way and he's
able to think this way and then what
happens is hey we're coming to the same
[__] conclusions what what is this
what is other it's really crazy when we
start seeing like all the DAT is lining
up and then then we and then that's what
ends up happening when we have so much
data points from all these other things
that we're looking at and stuff and this
is what a lot of people in the red pill
like this is why even when I think about
red pill I look at the blue pill side
the the black pillars and the and the
red pill and [__] not the purple pill
but like but I look at all these sides
and stuff cuz like there's like I mean
some of the smartest people in the red
pill space in terms of like sexual
Dynamics between men and women or the
black pillars they hyper intelligent
guys are just [__] on looks or they're
[__] [__] and they' have no hope
or some [__] because they have a
chemical imbalance
yeah although I think sometimes those
guys they the black pill guys will say
well no we're all about the stats we're
all about the data it's scientifically
driven but actually when you look at the
data they're using and you're looking at
the interpretations they're putting on
that data it's it's flawed you know and
they'll often say for example take data
data from the dating apps and they'll
say well look look look at what's
happening on the dating apps you know
women only go for you know this top
percentile of men fine but obviously the
dating apps are fundamentally skewed
towards looks in the first place right
so you're going to have a certain type
of outcome there that you're not NE is
not necessarily going to be replicated
in real life but they don't take that
into account right yeah it's the same
with Finance right there's like
different ways that people can take get
advantages right and it's whether you
exploit those properly or not it's not
necessarily like when you got the black
pill on politics or Finance it's like oh
wo is me there's no opportunity here
we're getting screwed by inflation so
I'm just going to give up right and
that's what a lot of the Zoomer
generation kind of feels like the moment
I think because um they're so far in
debt they just they look at the you know
getting out of that bucket they're just
like it's impossible yeah you know and
then comes in cryptocurrency that people
are like well maybe I just have to be
crazy enough to give this a shot right
and for those who do and actually put it
in there um they basically can you know
have that you got to be a risk taker
right it pushes you towards more risk if
you're under 22 like be all in on
something who cares like your money all
the money you make from like 15 to 22 is
basically useless I not useless but like
spend it on alcohol you spend on alcohol
this [__] whatever anyway you spend on
your [__] girlfriend you know how
many I told the story to like there's
like I I helped so many these [__]
kids with that I when we when we had all
these employees I helped so many these
kids buy coins early on I they they had
the chance all of them had the chance to
be multi-millionaires make $1 to $3
million or at least make a [__] like
$800,000 but the moment that they had
like they it crossed 100 grand for them
and stuff or like they they ended up
taking the money out and just spending
[__] [__] like I knew like I I knew
that already like it was going to happen
you going buyself a truck you a
girlfriend and then like all of them did
this [__] and like and then I have their
moms tell me like my [__] son's a
[__]
idiot cuz I you know CU they would tell
me like Miguel are you sure the safe
yeah you're fine like it's they make
good money they made a lot of money
really the money went up really quick
and they took profits too early and
stuff and because as soon as they got
that it's because the social media they
wanted to I I I told them like at least
keep more than half only like one guy
kept like half of it the rest of them
it's like gone already but and they did
it yeah for girls for
[__] no return wasted assets yeah the
lowest quality of women ever in human
history one in
25 so so pearly things where can people
follow you oh um you can follow me just
pear oh wait no I switched my channel
name to Pearl justl just Pearl yeah yeah
it's Pearl now and then uh pearly things
on Twitter with a z and then on
Instagram just pearly things one if you
want to come on you know my show which
is you know I bring on some women in
London if any of you are in London uh DM
the guy in my bio on Instagram not me if
you messaged me about it I'll leave you
unseen and the Day game master himself
man Troy Francis yeah thanks for having
me on Miguel it's been a great show uh
yeah just real TR Francis on YouTube on
Twitter and on Instagram and on Tik Tok
as well so when is your next classes
when are you doing when are you going to
be teaching are you teaching like
something here in Vegas or what are you
um there's if anyone's in Vegas and they
want some coaching I'm around this
weekend so we can you know we could so
drop me a line uh troytroy francis.com
drop me an email and we can have a chat
about that uh aside from that I'm going
to be uh if well if you're in the states
drop me an email because I might be in
New York for a bit I might be back in
Miami so drop me drop me an email and
then beyond that we've got a class
myself and James are doing a class in
Columbia nice uh on I think it's the
weekend of the 22nd of October so if
you're up for coming out to to bitar me
and James task who's one of the you know
the greatest day Gamers you know in in
operation today and we're just going to
be having a pretty wild crazy kind of
debed few days in Colombia so are you
going to CME uh yes good good good good
good we'll be there too and stuff we'll
be speaking absolutely yeah yeah
definitely and stuff and Charlie uh
cultivate crypto on every platform so
just look on Instagram Twitter YouTube
what uh whatever just cultivate crypto
and uh yeah do it on YouTube subscribe
baby basically if you're watching me
right now you're watching me so there
you go dog cost crypto everywhere but
thank you so much for joining me I'll
catch you guys on Thursday at 8:00 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time and uh well we
have so many guests of [__] we might
even have a zerka stream pretty soon so
hey peace